i mean these people are going nuts for
you out there it's crazy this is bananas
right
i honestly feel a little bit numb
like this has been the most incredible
experience this whole journey from the
day i got cast and my agents are here we
were just talking about the moment i got
my first call back and we really thought
like oh wow maybe i could actually get
this job and here we are today promoting
spider-man 3 like i am blown away to
share with my friends my family honestly
this means the world to me and you know
i was just talking to kevin feige and
you heard amy announce that they want to
do another trilogy kevin said we want
tom back for this next for the next one
we want him back well that's great news
that's awesome kevin is he's he's the
king amy is the queen
they're like my parents i love them to
bits and if they'll have me back i'll be
there i love that i love hearing that
because you know they're going to have
you back we want you back they want you
back out there you've got some great new
stars in the mcu you've got angelina
jolie harry styles people like that who
are the newbies that you're excited to
work with next
i want to work with florence pugh i
think she's amazing she's so good in
that movie and all the movies that she's
done
i think she's fantastic so i think a
really cool spider-man black widow movie
would be a fun little twist this is this
is the most physically demanding
spider-man movie you've done do you
think correct yeah so how are you
feeling about that and tackling that
they're losing things i think zendaya
just sounds like they're just showed up
[Applause]
that's her no no that's i want to see
what she has on can we watch is she
going to walk down here
[Applause]
it's her let's watch
oh she's going in she's going in she's
going in she's going that's definitely
there that definitely was that
definitely is
but but really quickly how do you feel
because this was the most physically
demanding
i mean it was tough it was tough but
again tough for all the right reasons
you know playing this character is
incredibly physical the fighting the
swinging the jumping everything but it
really comes across on screen you know
it's really important to these films
that they feel authentic in a world that
is so full of you know cgi and all these
kind of crazy things so to have as much
authentic action as possible is so
important and that's why i'm so lucky to
have george cottle in my corner my
coordinator to make me safe and also
look like a badass
you